allons danemark où des députés ont
adopté aujourd'hui avec une forte
majorité un projet de loi très
controversée sur l'immigration
cette loi vise à décourager les réfugiés
de demander l'asile au danemark
elle va notamment permettre aux
autorités de confisquer l'argent et les
biens des réfugiés ces mesures
traduisent le profond malaise qui
entoure tout la crise migratoire en
europe
voyons d'abord le reportage d'alexandra
schatz car le flot ne tarit pas malgré
l'hiver et le mauvais temps 2000
réfugiés par jour en moyenne sont
arrivés aux portes de l'europe en
janvier
les naufrages continue au moins 35
personnes se sont noyées en mer egée
dont dix sept enfants vendredi dernier
et ce qui arrive à mettre le pied sur le
sol européen se frappent de plus en plus
à des portes fermées dernier pays en
date le danemark son parlement vient
d'adopter une loi controversée
elle prévoit la confiscation des biens
des demandeurs d'asile
tout ce qui dépasse 2000 dollars
canadiens argent bijoux tout peut être
confisqué à l'exception des ordinateurs
portables des téléphones et des objets à
forte valeur sentimentale comme des
alliances nous faisons notre part en
matière de réfugiés affirme la ministre
de l'immigration si nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui ce que nous voulons diminuer
notre part du fardeau
le danemark qui compte un peu plus de
cinq millions et demi d'habitants a
accueilli quinze mille réfugiés l'an
dernier c'est trop clame le nouveau
gouvernement de droite élu en juin sur
des promesses de mettre fin à cette
déferlante
mais les organisations internationales
s'inquiètent d'autant plus qu'avec la
nouvelle loi les réfugiés devront
dorénavant attendre trois années plutôt
qu'une avant de pouvoir faire venir
leurs familles cette loi alimente le
sentiment de peur et de discrimination
elle va à l'encontre du principe
fondamental en lois internationales
celui de l'unité de la famille dit le
porte parole du haut commissariat
réfugié ces mesures seront elles
suffisantes pour empêcher les migrants
de venir frapper aux portes du danemark
rien n'est moins sûr alexandre une
nouvelle loi donc décrié par les
organisations de défense des droits de
la personne
on ne semble pas croire que ça va
décourager ils demandèrent d'asie alors
qu'elle est qu'elle sera vraiment sa
portée en fait la porte et c'est
vraiment s'est dirigé vers la population
danoise c'est dire à la population de la
loi ce qui est très anti réfugiés de
plus en plus 70% des danois aujourd'hui
sont contre la venue massive de réfugiés
c'est de leur dire vous voyez on les
traite pas si bien que ça et d'ailleurs
c'est sorti dans les débats les assistés
sociaux danois à qui on demande de se
départir un peu comme chez nous de tous
leurs avoirs avant qu'ils aient le droit
d'avoir de l'assistance sociale bien les
réfugiés ils logent à la même enseigne
alors c'est pour montrer à la population
danoise que le gouvernement ne l'est pas
est en train de bloquer cette cette
déferlante et c'est pas le seul pays à
le faire il ya d'autres pays en europe
qui adoptent des mesures semblables oui
en fait on ne savait pas mais déjà on
apprend dans la foulée de cette affaire
danoise que la suisse adopte et déjà
c'est une loi semblable il ya 20 ans
mais vous voyez c'est pas une question
d'argent parce que la suisse qui ne
permet pas aux réfugiés d'avoir plus de
1300 dollars canadiens équivalent de
1300 dollars canadiens et bien elle a
réussi à récolter en 2015 où il ya quand
même eu pas mal de réfugiés en suisse
trois cent mille dollars canadiens alors
c'est vraiment pas grand chose il ya
deux régions allemandes aussi la bavière
et la baden wurtenberg où on a adopté
les mêmes mesures avec des sommes un peu
différente mais ça n'a pas empêché et
les réfugiés de venir en allemagne vous
avez vu c'est plus d'un million de
réfugiés qui sont venus en allemagne
donc c'est pas c'est une mesure qui est
un peu de la poudre aux yeux ce qui est
plus grave aujourd'hui c'est la
fermeture des frontières en europe de
plus en plus de pays ferme
leurs frontières comme la suède comme
l'autriche partiellement ou entièrement
et si il continue à les fermer de façon
plus systématique et bien c'est un peu
la fin de l'europe la fin de la
circulation libre à l'intérieur de
l'espace robots et ça c'est un enjeu
extrêmement important et ça on est
vraiment dans un enjeu très important
merci beaucoup alexandra au plaisir